you actually started crying and it was
beautiful because you did it in real
time it was fantastic to this day people
always come up to me and say I saw that
with Bryce Dallas Howard did you guys
fake that no we didn't you absolutely
did it on camera that we have a clip of
that pretty amazing performance you give
so much and you get so little in return
I mean they really paying you enough for
what it's worth they're not really
paying you and I think that at some
point people should actually give Home
Depot with their Dukes it's not fair
it's a company it's in a company that
should be
so crazy
[Applause]
yeah it's pretty amazing but I was
thinking afterwards I don't know if you
were channeling a memory or what you
because I was I was talking about the
Home Depot and you cried that's the sign
that you're an amazing actor but I don't
know if that's a technique technical
it's it's something that can be learned
and taught and you just need to give me
a little bit of money right I am NOT an
actor I am always me is that something
seriously though yeah you could actually
do that everybody here could be crying
right you can get them crying during the
monologue but I mean do you want to hear
about it yeah yeah it's something I
could learn yes
so like you have water here yes so you
would wanted you want to be hydrated
obviously drink a lot of water okay okay
drink a lot of water mm-hmm and then you
know when you yawn how you isn't water
Ben works too yeah fine yeah I liquid um
I you know how like when you be on you
get you your soft palate lifts and you
like just do wrong with me right now
look everyone yawn like would you see
how your eyes start to tear mine are not
hearing look a really odd
we're really on and then you can and
then and there are some guess where I'm
doing this naturally and not you but
there are some where I'm like no if you
do it enough times then when you're
talking you can continue to lift it
continue lifting it okay uh-huh
I'm not even getting close yeah I'm
almost crying I know you are getting
tight on her
look this is she's actually got tears in
her eyes and it triggers it like just
talking about it for me like it's like a
physiological thing where I'm gonna have
to clear these tears away but they do it
just it's just further back no no help
me give me emotional give me something
okay give me an emotional okay so Conan
yeah um let me give relate with me okay
we've we've known each other for for 10
years yes I've been on your show on
Conan I'm never gonna see you again
you're not gonna go I'm never gonna see
you again what you're gonna see me again
[Applause]
why are you crying Oh crying without
even trying I've been yawning I think I
broke a world record for yawning yeah it
looks like you're eating an invisible
sub yeah nothing yeah no it's did you do
that well I just I started practicing
very young yeah okay what made you think
that I could do this on television
completely untrained by just yawning
well because I don't owe you anything
no I right now it's it's okay Conan I'm
sorry it's over it's over
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what I need that's why if I had
that crap I could be an actor listen we
are pulling if you pluck a nose here or
two that always helps it really does
why don't you come over here and do that
moment wish you were in the middle of
looking like an [ __ ] I didn't want
you